[Music]
i miss
traveling like i really do then just do
it
but i'm not going to just it's the guy
with the three ponytails i'm not going
to do it
but you know there are people that are
just doing it well not that kind of
doing it i'll do it
if it's legal like if the state is like
we're florida come on down why are you
stopping because there's disney world
disney world is there disneyland come on
universal florida
they own four good that's a good mickey
i had the same thought process i was
like why are you still like
oh disneyland what i'm saying is i
really miss international traveling
oh well you can't have everything what
about just going to hawaii right now you
have to wait two weeks in a hotel right
now
come on down to disneyland what about
mexico can you go to mexico now
i don't know wait what i think people
can go to mexico again but maybe it's
not international because it's your
second home it is
maybe you could go to nicaragua oh i've
heard about that
nicaragua nicaragua
yeah isaac was supposed to go to peru
this year oh he's a peruvian boy
yeah he was supposed to go to his his
father's side motherland
but it didn't happen father said
motherland yes his father's peruvian
anyway so uh the these
i have a story here of these two
strangers
never before ever so they never met
and then a week after they first met
online
they actually met in person and this
time it was in chicago on their way to
turkey
and they took a trip together as
complete strangers
so it's pretty inspiring online lovers
not lovers platonic just
travel buddies strictly yeah travel why
so what a waste why would a waste what
do you mean why
not everyone's trying to [ __ ] are they
the opposite sex yes they are
see oh so that means it's platonic for
her
and then he's got an ulterior movement
oh yeah he's a nice guy he's trying to
figure it out he ain't getting none
my dude friend zoned ass [ __ ]
just for once think that there are some
decent human beings i have platonic
friends
i actually have a lot of girlfriends
yeah so what the hell and he's trying to
[ __ ] all of them
no he's plowing through him
if you're his friend you should look at
yourself right now in the mirror because
he's coming for you
or in you all right or look at the
camera i'm not into
incest yeah that's like inception it
only works when you friend zone them
yeah okay i get it oh but anyway so this
this uh
these two strangers here josiah and
therese
josiah
yeah so i think it's only enforcing the
narrative sorry what was the name of the
girl
teresa yeah so josiah
he said that he was supposed to go to
japan with a friend but japan is closed
hayden has japan so he's from iowa and
so
he was looking into other places he
could possibly visit because he still
wanted to travel
and he was looking for a country that
was open to
americans because a lot of countries
around the world are completely close to
americans
we could go to turkey yes that's why
nadeem went
just went yeah exactly turkey why
for the turkeys i thought you're gonna
go fix your teeth oh well that no i
don't need to fix it
i mean even though we can i don't feel
right doing that
what kind of food is it turkey food oh
wow i follow so many ig accounts from
turkey where they it's just
different restaurants in turkey and it
looks so bomb yeah they got they got the
uh the holiday ham
isn't it crazy we've been there like
four times and not once in
a whole thing they got pumpkin pie apple
pie whoa
we got pilgrims there
turkey bacon turkey sausage awesome dude
i can't wait
so when josiah
excuse me
i thought i only heard that so he was
looking into croatia
oh they just closed yes i wanted to go
there so bad
rosacea oh you should it's gorgeous it's
so pretty especially in austria
you've been huh is it worth it like if
you don't go on the beaches though and
you go inland yes it's so beautiful it's
like an untouched
croatia yes yeah but like during this
during the summer is better than the
winter
wow oh yeah it's just gorgeous yeah yeah
the place is awesome during the winter
europe is sad during the summer huh or
spring for us i don't know what
what it was for them i'm just saying
it's amazing during summer
okay i know what you mean hot girls oh
[ __ ] oh yeah they are all chocolates
girls
we were at them no we're at a beach and
this chick was just
suntanning topless i don't want to i
don't go anymore i mean as soon as she
noticed us
she kind of like covered up because like
it's kind of weird like these are all
well the problem with new beaches is
usually not hot people it wasn't nude
she was just talking she was sneaking
over at the top i don't like that
you don't like sneaking toplessness at
family beaches
it's on it's unsightly no okay i didn't
ask for nobody wants to see that i
didn't ask to be horny
okay okay control yourself it's sexually
distracting for me
um put some clothes on and be wind your
eyeballs
just gouge them out wow
so back to the story so they were
looking into croatia but you needed a
negative covet test within 72 hours
that's timothy was looking
and but turkey didn't have that
requirement so
they say come here to turkey you could
smoke hookah
and hang out and get your teeth fixed i
don't care if you got corona
is that what they're saying probably
okay so then that's when
so he he wanted to go and do this trip
he booked the trip
but he didn't want to go alone and none
of his friends were down to go with him
because no one's trying to travel
so then he turned to a facebook group
that is followed by 40 000 people
where it offers advice on ways to save
money on the road and like to travel
and stuff so then he ended up posting a
message
saying like you know hey uh if anyone
wants to join or meet up
let me know i'll be in turkey from these
dates
and so then that's when therese hit him
up and said hey what are your plans i'm
considering a solo trip over the same
week because she was supposed to be
going to
wow she's so brave she's she's from
denver she's very brave
do you think she was like he's safe
or either that she has the knowledge to
protect herself if she were to be
probably yeah
so she was supposed to be in south
africa during that time that exact same
week
she had already requested off from work
and so
it was just like a crazy coincidence
would you do that just like any old man
on facebook and say
you trying to go somewhere i want to go
somewhere let's roll
personally me myself i'm a very
spontaneous adventurous person i
probably would say yes
what to a random person a random male
two probably would have said yes i don't
know how i feel about that
she asked him i was about to go to new
york for new year's eve by myself that's
different
and then you went with a random male who
happened to be something i was already
sleeping with
oh true yeah well if you already suck
this dick that's different
yeah see there's comfort levels that
you've already uh did she suck his dick
already
no she's gonna platonic does she have
invisalign
because i heard that's better if it's
invisalign then it's not real dick
sucking right she's really good okay
oh true even talking about just turn
those will burn out
it's so slow so even as a man that
travels alone
i will not do this you wouldn't travel
with it well i didn't even get to finish
i wouldn't drive over with nobody okay
tell me the details of the story because
it's actually
and then we'll judge a week after
they initially exchanged messages online
or actually
an hour later from the time that he told
her his
itinerary and everything an hour later
is when she messaged
him after telling him that she she was
gonna sleep on it but she didn't an hour
later
she booked it she booked all the the
trip with the same itinerary
and excuse me and then so from then on
they just kept chatting online
and in the following days they they were
booking tours and transportation and all
this stuff
and eventually they ended up meeting up
in chicago
and they both got business class turkish
airlines they're
rich no no no
you're gonna flip your [ __ ] when i tell
you how much they spent because they're
travel hackers right uh that's why they
were on that page the facebook travel
hack page
yeah i guess they probably yeah yeah
they're good looking they would make a
good couple they have a
they have a similar smile they're
brother and sister
oh snaps never mind not a good couple
okay
twisted he looks like a decent dude i i
would travel with them and feel safe
yeah
i'm pretty sure she did her homework and
also she's capable of protecting herself
what if she's a murderer or something or
that thank you thank you
it's okay because girl murderers are hot
is that a
secret fantasy of yours nah i'm just
saying whatever
even if a girl is scary like
i don't think you've seen some some of
the mug shots my friend never mind yeah
okay so anyway so then the girl
uh therese she ends up telling her
friends like like yeah i know it's
freaking crazy i'm going on a trip with
a stranger
but going with a stranger you kind of
get the best of both worlds because you
don't feel obligated to that person
so if they don't want to do something or
if you don't end up gelling with them or
whatever you can just go your own way
so
[Applause]
as it was coming out of my mouth i'm
like here we go but anyway so then they
ended up booking separate rooms
obviously because they're not trying to
sleep
together and so she was like you know we
have our own space
if there's any issues we don't have to
stick it out through the whole trip
it's fine if i get her pregnant i'm
[ __ ] out of here oh so
it works out for her because he's like
the bodyguard
kind yeah it works out for him he has
companionship if he wants to go eat or
somebody he has company and he doesn't
have to be a creep and pick up a girl
on the street yes that's kind of cool
exactly that's why i'm like dude i think
i'd be down for this
but then don't you ever get into a space
where you're like i gotta go to dinner
with you and [ __ ]
no so they found out like on the flight
because they had that long ass flight to
turkey
from chicago and during that whole
flight like they had
they had great conversation they just
had good chemistry to begin with
so the entire trip they ended up going
like on a hot air balloon
oh they're gonna [ __ ] dude come on yeah
they're gonna [ __ ] first thing they did
was go on a hop-on hop-off bus so they
could see like a tour bus kind of thing
and then they went to like
every single major tourist attraction in
istanbul
when you have fun somewhat with someone
it gets it gets it going get the
endorphins
especially in like a a random place
right like a
travel when you're in tourist mode come
on they look like a [ __ ] cute couple
man
yeah honestly they do they [ __ ] they
didn't have to stick it out they had
they were sticking it in you know
oh my boy
[Laughter]
you know what's cool about this though
is that is kind of how you can tell if
you can get along in a relationship
exactly how you can tell
if you're living with someone you're
traveling with someone that's who you
know
you [ __ ] know someone when you travel
how is traveling with casey is it very
fun
fantastic
but in the middle and like during and
like sometimes like all the time
sometimes it's great wow
cool well there's reasons but anyway
back to this so in total one reason
we're married how about that that's a
good enough reason yeah sure
yeah no baggage whatsoever
so how much did they spend i wanna thank
you i wanna know fantastic
fantastic guess how much they spent 29
no no this is this is including business
class flights
hotel costs and spending money how much
do you think they have 14 honda 425
6 000. how long were they out there a
little over a week oh
625 700 600 oh damn
okay well you guys it's kind of close a
thousand i came the closest i think
1400 right thank you technically 700 is
closer to the thought well i can't do
that kind of math
but then the rule is if you go over then
it does you're not the closest
that's the rule so i'm the closest oh
[ __ ] that was him
the prize is right
yep a thousand dollars really good to
end this to end the story
the cutest part of all is that they they
she says that she didn't really
necessarily think that they would
turn into a real friendship but it has
there are actual friends now and they've
talked about meeting
when they get back to the states and
because they're only a two-hour flight
away from each other
and so he was saying that he's going to
be visiting his mom
i mean sorry he's gonna be taking a trip
to spain with his mom and may
and therese might join yeah i'm sure
they'll just have
a great friendship time and i'm sure
like she's like oh yeah we're just
friends and he's like
i better get laid from this one we went
all over the [ __ ] place are you
kidding me bro
why does it always go down like that
where the girls are like oh he's like my
best
friend and then the guy's all like oh i
want her so
i'm so sad that that's that you guys
can't even fathom platonic relations you
know why
are you kidding of course he wants her
you can't be friends with chicks like
that you can't
yeah i mean like guys are wired
differently has there
ever been a chick that you guys rejected
yeah when they're ugly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you